[MUSIC]
To an entrepreneur and investor is
somebody that you confide in when
you have difficulties,
somebody that you can have
meaningful conversations with,
who can challenge you,
who can be a sounding board.
Somebody who can open up doors,
Reaction represents all of that.
[MUSIC]
>> So Reaction was launched on
campus from the Stanford
executive program.
>> This idea of how do you bring
a community together that can
elevate entrepreneurs experiences.
>> We had 225 leaders from
throughout the world,
every continent, we set a mission
to improve a billion lives this
decade by scaling innovations that
would change the world.
>> I was all in.
>> We have alumni from the Stanford
executive program classes all
the way from 2014 to 22.
>> We really enjoyed being
together.
So the first thing we thought
about is, hey, how do we
keep this community going together?
>> We had three problems we were
trying to solve, the first was how
could we continue to learn?
>> I believe in lifelong learning.
The way you consume information,
the way you learn these days,
that has changed forever.
>> The second was thinking about
what we could build.
>> We were a group of 225,
you realized the potential and
the power.
>> And then the third was around
purpose, thinking about
what we'd want to look back on,
what will we be proud about, and
to collectively accomplish
something that none of us
ever could have done individually.
So in terms of improving a billion
lives, we focus on
the macro-problems of the world in
health of course, heart disease,
mental health, chronic disease,
and most recently, sustainability.
>> I became involved with Reaction
because I am a founder of a local
bio manufacturing company and
we were looking for investors.
What Mango Materials is focused on
is changing the plastics industry
completely.
So we're looking for
a very specific type of investor,
one who sees the future in the same
way we do.
We are technologists,
we are engineers and scientists who
have created this new technology,
but we need partners and investors
to help us see this through.
>> Innovator like Molly has a lot
of support in terms of capital,
what we need to do is to bring
something to Molly that's
different.
>> So Reaction helps by
facilitating the scaling of
the technology globally.
>> By organizing a global set of
Stanford alumni into this fund,
we're able to help her to open
doors throughout the world in a way
that is creating more value and
improving more lives faster.
>> We see climate change and
plastic pollution has two of
the largest threats that our
planet is facing today.
In order for these solutions,
these innovations,
the science to reach the different
parts of the planet it can impact,
it needs to have the leadership and
influence in those areas and
we can provide that.
>> So by being part of an ecosystem
of changemakers, who believe the
world can be changed through novel
innovation and new technologies and
new business platforms,
that gives us a path to the future
that we all really want to see.
>> And in terms of the industries
that are impacted between energy
and health and transportation and
manufacturing and agriculture,
we have access to all of
these different industries.
And play a unique role in helping
them to plug in and
to connect with the leaders that
can influence decisions,
collectively we can help to
solve the climate crisis challenge.
On campus at the GSB,
we focused a lot on their slogan,
which is to change lives,
change organizations, and
change the world.
Naturally, as leaders come
to Stanford,
their lives are transformed, they
can transform their organizations.
But changing the world,
we thought we can really play
an important role.
>> Changing the world,
the best thing you can do is enable
entrepreneurs to build companies,
enable them to invest in
communities with global impact.
>> Makes Reaction different is our
community of investors,
of executives, of entrepreneurs
throughout the world, and
their desire to be hands on to
be active in terms of helping
the innovators to really take their
solutions further than they could
go on their own.
So our ambition is to create
the most global, most influential,
and most impactful Stanford
investment community in the world.
We're very proud of what's been
accomplished so far, but so
excited for where this is going to
go in the future and seeing
this dream really come to life.
I'm Molly Morse, CEO and
co-founder of Mango Materials.
>> My name is Babu Sivadasan,
one of the founding partners
of Reaction.
I'm Dan Matthies,
I'm a co-founder and
managing partner of Reaction.